where'd my breakfast go
where did this go i ate it you ate it
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to preserve
american food ways specifically the
hamburger
here's a weird one for you we're talking
about the loose meat sandwich from the
midwest
is it a hamburger we're not entirely
sure
is it amazing absolutely depending on
where you are in the midwest
loose meat sandwich can be called a
tavern it could be called a new way if
you're in wichita kansas
i've heard it called a loose hamburger
sandwich in illinois
but the core of the loose meat sandwich
is actually in
iowa it's in the burger family that's
what i like to say think sloppy joe
without the slop there's no tomato based
sauce like you'd have in a sloppy joe
when you bite into a loose meat sandwich
if your eyes are closed you do taste
hamburger it has
all the elements of a hamburger bun beef
seasoning in this case just salt
mustard onion pickle it tastes like a
burger you open your eyes you go ah
what happened so it's my job to bring
this
iowa specialty what is this it's my job
to bring you think we're amateurs here
come on
just because we're just for like a
family team over here
the family crew we know we're doing okay
it's my job
to bring this iowa specialty what is
doing now
it's my job to bring this iowa specialty
to you
let's do this this is my great
grandfather's cast iron skillet i'm
using which has a lot of history and a
lot of flavor in it
so unlike every other burger you've ever
seen me make
whether it's a ball it's smashed or it's
a it's a formed patty of some sort this
is actually
it's like we're making chili in a way
[Music]
i'm crumbling beef the difference is
that the cookers they use in the midwest
they have this grease drain at the
bottom a drainage system that allows the
meat to stay
in the cooker and the fat to drain off
because you really want to take most of
the fat out
she didn't know she went to the bathroom
no pee breaks come back here
i lost 50 of my crew first time i went
to taylor's
in marshalltown iowa i learned some
pretty cool slang
whenever they put condiments on the bun
ahead of the meat coming it's called
doping the bun
mustard onion and pickle
the bun's been doped but i got some
other ones though there's lots of burger
slang out there some of my favorites i
put right here
let's go to school ready okay
all the way you've probably heard of
that before all the way
simply means the burger the way they
serve it with everything on it if you're
in texas and you order
a burger with mayo it's called a city
burger
but if you were in oklahoma and you
asked for a burger with mayo on it
you get an educated burger
then there's squoes look at that word
okay squoze actually is
well it's the same as the past tense of
squeezed if you get a burger at dubby's
cafe
in kentucky it's deep fried you can get
your burger squeezed
or unsqueezed unsqueezed
see that unsqueezed which means that
dovi's you don't want the grease
squeezed out of your burger because it's
deep fried okay we're cooking
oh [ __ ] jesus sorry it's broken okay
well
look at that it's not a hamburger
it's a pile of beef that's cooking
and looks good okay taking the fat out
this is not heresy this is just the way
it goes
the one seasoning you'll find in most
blue speech places in iowa and beyond
is salt just salt loose meats
nothing on this sandwich loose meat
sandwich other than
mustard pickling how many times am i
gonna say that it's because it's
important to know that
this is very very important don't put
ketchup on your loose meat sandwich
normally they'd serve it on a piece of
wax paper i'm gonna serve mine on a
plate
they take it in their hand and they take
a spoon of beef and they just do ah
that's hot that's yeah okay
how do they not burn themselves look at
that
that's it and then they do this and then
they wrap it up
in wax paper
and is served with a spoon a loose meat
sandwich
but hang on before we eat that we're
gonna make a milkshake
when you're eating a loose meat sandwich
it's customary to get something like a
milkshake
this is a milkshake mixer but it's not
just any mixer
this is a 1944 hamilton beach
model number 33. is gorgeous
this is a piece of food history it's
older than my mother this thing
and it still functions perfectly listen
you hear that it smells like ozone
sorry about that sorry one of my
favorite milkshakes to make and i made a
lot with this thing already
is the mocha malt it's so basic it's
coffee ice cream
chocolate syrup malt powder a little bit
of milk not much milk
oh yeah
not much a little bit not much now malt
powder this is
malted barley with milk in it basically
so good a lot of this oh
you're gotta
oh oh [ __ ] let's just do
there we go oh look at that it's time to
put two and two together a loose meat
sandwich
and my milk a malt oh
it's a burger wait it's not a burger
it's a loose meat it's not a burger
it's a loose meat sandwich
oh my god this is heaven right now this
is heaven people
this is what heaven looks like a mocha
malt and a loose meat sandwich
oh i'll see you next time when we
make a burger that's actually a burger
[Music]
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where